and now ladies and gentlemen is the
crowning jewel and this evening
dedicated to achievement I give you a
lady who has enriched the motion picture
industry from the day she became a part
of it
a very great lady of the stage today she
is the great lady of films
it is a signal honor to the winner of
the 21st award for the best motion
picture of the year that the Oscar
should be presented by miss Ethel
Barrymore
I'm deeply honored to present this award
I believe that the public as well as the
members of the Academy realize what
miraculous teamwork goes into the making
of great motion pictures the best
picture encompasses the finest skills of
every craft the finished product playing
in thousands of theaters hundreds of
thousands of performances it was
millions of people the richest
entertainment on earth each firing
motion picture leaves an indelible mark
on the memories of those who see it and
in time when the heir 1948 is called to
mind among the important and nostalgic
memories would be the film chosen here
tonight the nominated pictures are
Hamlet J Arthur rank Two Cities film
universal international Brigitta
Johnny Belinda Warner Brothers the red
shoes J Arthur rank Archer heed a lion
British the Snakepit
20th Century Fox treasure sierra madre
warner brothers and the winner and that
J Arthur ray
speaking as a stand-in I wish to say on
behalf of sir Lawrence the tremendous
gratification it is to be selected by a
jury of one's peers I'm sure that Larry
who lived and worked amongst us for so
many years and looked back on the
rewards and the plaudits of the world
that have fallen to his lot recently to
the knighthood by his King to all the
various rewards that have come to him
none can be more touching or more
gratifying than one of this kind from
his own profession
so let us may I join with you to
congratulate him on this award and to
congratulate ourselves in having chosen
him twice this evening
miss Ethel Barrymore in a manner which
gives us of the Academy a real sense of
our responsibility to the honest
creators in the motion picture industry
you have closed our program good night
ladies and gentlemen and thank you very
much
you